bonjour jean-gario merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de
Loire-Atlantique donc du groupe les
indépendants en République et territoire
on va parler bien sûr de l'audition du
préfet de leur Atlantique dans quelques
instants mais d'abord on le voit
l'actualité c'est toujours la
proposition de loi Eliott qui a donc été
adopté hier en commission adoptée mais
vider de sa substance puisque la
majorité a supprimé l'article qui
supprime la retraite à 64 ans avant de
parler du fond d'abord un mot sur la
forme on l'a vu la séance et la journée
était très agitée hier à l'Assemblée
nationale majorité opposition ce sont
activées invectiver pendant des heures
la nuque a quitté la commission quel
regard vous portez sur ce qui s'est
passé
regarde de la du respect de la
Constitution c'est le point de base
puisque la notion d'avendement qui a été
mise en place en 1958 porte cette
possibilité que nous avons de changer et
de modifier la loi mais à l'impose
qu'une la recette recevabilité d'un
amendement ne doit pas entraîner des
augmentations ou des charges
supplémentaires pour l'État donc en
l'occurrence cette article entraînait de
Lourdes de charge et c'est donc un
constitutionnel et ça ne peut être
rejeté vous si vous étiez en commission
vous auriez voté la suppression de cet
article c'est pas la suppression
d'article c'est d'y recevabilité de
l'article du regard à la au respect de
la Constitution qui prévoit que dans
trois cas les amendements ne peuvent pas
être acceptés et heureusement qu'on
n'accepte pas les amendements parce que
accepter tous les Allemands et bien
c'est bloqué complètement le
fonctionnement du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale pourquoi parce
qu'on l'a vu en 2006 on a eu une
situation équivalente c'était pour une
loi sur l'énergie où il y a eu 134 000
amendements qui ont été déposés par
l'opposition de Chirac ça totalement
détruit toute capacité d'aller au bout
de cette loi pourquoi parce que
normalement ben ça prend du temps chaque
demandement va être avant l'hémicycle
une prise de temps et surtout honte
débordement pour faire en sorte que et
bien il soit impossible d'aller au bout
du débat et on l'a vu encore récemment
avec la réforme des retraites et ses
regrettable le jeu des amendements qui
sont des jeux qui portent souvent sur
des anneaux aucun sens la première
ministre sur la dit hier avec des sous
amendements moi je l'ai vu au Sénat vous
avez des sous amendements sur la base
d'un rapport qui devait être remis le
1er janvier 2026 et les sénateurs qui
voulaient bloquer cette soirée-là on
aurait fait cette note 8 à faire
n'importe quoi parce que le premier
abonnement c'était de passer du 1er
septembre 2006 aux 2 septembre 2010
l'amendement suivant s'était passé du
1er septembre au 3 septembre etc jusqu'à
la fin du mois novembre il y avait 90
amendements qui ne voulaient strictement
rien dire c'est à dire qu'il faut bien
voir qu'il y a un jeu que moi je ne
partage pas et pour moi c'est vraiment
contre sens de démocratie faut arrêter
ce cette façon de d'agir qui est
d'éviter de parler du fond en mettant
des choses totalement stupides des
modifications totalement stupides qui
permettent de faire en sorte que cela
avance pas c'est très bien que la banque
bande passera pas on cherche pas à ce
qui la passe on cherche
pour la démocratie c'est ce qui s'est
passé notamment hier à savoir que du
coup les amendements n'ont pas été
examinés que le 8 juin il n'y aura
sûrement pas de vote sur ce texte ça
c'est pas dommageable pour la démocratie
non parce que on est parti sur une
technique qui porte de le fait de mettre
sur la table des Allemands stupides qui
n'ont aucun sens à une seule fin de
faire que le débat ne se produise pas et
cette technique est à mon avis
inacceptable pour ma part des
amendements j'en ai fait un énormément
je peux vous assurer que chaque
commandement a du sens et mérite d'être
débattu et d'être argumenté qui passe ou
qui passe pas c'est c'est là que je la
démocratie mais lorsque vous savez que
de toute façon ce que vous présentez n'a
aucun sens changement d'une date par une
autre et en le faisant ça contre toute
l'année et pourquoi pas changer leur par
une autre heure ça n'a aucun sens mais
vous le faites et à partir de là et bien
vous savez que vous allez tourner en
rond et que le résultat c'est qu'on
n'aura pas parlé du fond et ça c'est
inacceptable à une pression populaire
maximum mardi lors de la journée de
mobilisation est-ce que ce qui s'est
passé hier ça risque de relancer la
contestation contre la réforme
alors justement ce jeu des amendements
ce jeu de bloquer le Parlement dans son
débat de fond conduit forcément et bien
à pousser vers la rue
la discussion qui aurait dû sereinement
se produire au Parlement c'est un jeu
très dangereux auquel joue les
parlementaires de l'Assemblée nationale
que nous évitons au Sénat le mieux qu'on
peut et qui permet finalement d'arriver
à quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
serein beaucoup plus pesé et beaucoup
plus réfléchi et beaucoup plus justifié
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le Parlement
côté Assemblée nationale se trompe
totalement dans son mode de
fonctionnement et ceux qui en sont les
responsables c'est les premiers qui
diront bah voilà pourquoi on est dans la
dans la rue mais c'est eux qu'entraîne
le phénomène de la rue c'est eux qui
poussent à des actions de violence et
d'agressivité quand on les entend quand
la façon dont ils fonctionnent c'est
c'est de vindication qui est la leur
pour moi c'est un c'est pas ça la
fonction parlementaire
on va revenir sur la question des
violences envers les élus notamment les
élus locaux lors de son audition Sénat
après sa démission le maire de
Saint-Brévin s'était dit abandonné par
l'État il avait mis en cause le préfet
de leur Atlantique hier vous avez
additionné ce préfet de Loire-Atlantique
ainsi que le sous-préfère on va voir les
temps forts de cette audition avec
Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour et Audrey hier la
commission des lois dictionnait donc le
préfet le sous-préfet de
Loire-Atlantique dans l'affaire de la
démission du maire de Saint-Brévin les
pins après des menaces et l'incendie
criminels de son domicile représentant
de l'État qui estime avoir joué leur
rôle aux côtés des mers André oui et
tous les deux sont revenus de manière
extrêmement détaillée et chronologique
sur cette affaire qui commence en fait
au printemps 2021 quand il est décidé
d'agrandir un centre d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile dans la commune il
faut souligner tout de même que le
préfet a pris ses fonctions en janvier
2023 le sous-préfet était en poste
depuis plus longtemps en 2018 en tout
cas d'après eux à chaque événement
l'État a été aux côtés du maire écouté
à chaque étape de ce dossier et
particulièrement que depuis la situation
c'est fortement durci c'est-à-dire
depuis la toute fin de l'année 2022 les
services de l'État chacun dans leur rôle
et préfets les sous préfets dans leur
mission respective les forces de l'ordre
tout particulièrement la gendarmerie
départementale l'opérateur désigné pour
gérer le dossier ont été constamment
présent
on consacré énormément de temps et
d'énergie à la gestion de cette affaire
la commune en général assez tranquille
de Saint-Brévin à cet été secoué par
cette affaire mais elle n'a jamais été
laissée seule dans les difficultés
alors une prise de parole qui contraste
avec celle du maire auditionnée par les
sénateurs il y a 15 jours Yannick Moretz
qui fasse à eux c'était dit abandonner
par l'État et c'est vrai que malgré les
justifications du Préfet et du
sous-préfet les sénateurs ont eu
plusieurs fois le sentiment que les
choses c'était en animé doucement sans
que rien de radical ne soit fait pour
arrêter cela ça a été souligné quelques
exemples le Maire demande l'interdiction
d'une manifestation on lui refuse au
motif que les conditions d'interdiction
ne sont pas respectées ils reçoivent des
tracts haineux on lui répond que seul la
justice peut les interdire et il faut
attendre l'incendie de ces voitures pour
qu'une protection soit mise en place
d'ailleurs après cette incendie le maire
n'a reçu que des coups de téléphone de
la préfecture ça a choqué certains
sénateurs notamment le sénateur
socialiste
Usain Bourget je vous propose de
l'écouter avec la réponse du sous-préfet
dans la foulée
ou l'autre vous êtes allé à Saint-Brévin
pour témoigner le soutien de l'État au
maire de Saint-Brévin ce qui nous avait
surpris et qui m'avait moi
personnellement heurté c'est d'apprendre
que l'un ou l'autre était allé à Pornic
48 heures après l'incendie et personne
n'avait pris le soin de s'arrêter à
Saint-Brevin qui a 15 à 20 minutes je
regardais un sur ma paye itinéraire ni à
l'aller ni au retour pour rendre visite
au maire de Saint-Brevin et ça je ne le
comprends pas j'ai eu le maire le jour
de l'incendie
je n'ai pas perçu de demande
particulière de sa part à ce moment-là
peut-être à tort mais
j'ai pas ensuite eu le réflexe de
l'appeler pour lui dire je viens je
viens chez vous c'est exact monsieur le
sénateur on va reparler du contexte qui
a largement été évoqué contestation de
la réforme des retraites mais ils vous
ont convaincu le préfet le sous-préfet
hier
oui mon convaincu parce que ce sont des
personnes honnêtes ce sont des personnes
sincères ce sont des personnes de
qualité qui ont joué de fin que exercer
leur fonction avec le sentiment d'agir
comme il devait le faire
cette audition a pour objectif de donner
laisser le point de vue de part et
d'autre et de voir comment se fait-il
que ce n'est pas bien fonctionné je
crois que chacun tire des conclusions
pour soi-même et c'est ça l'avantage de
cette audition qui a permis de se dire
finalement j'aurais peut-être dû faire
ça c'est très facile de voir les choses
une fois que tout était d'affaires est
terminé si j'ose dire ou du moins
qu'elle est arrivé à son paroxystes
c'est plus facile mais c'est vrai que ce
regard porté sur ce que les événements
qui se sont passés chacun apportant ces
arguments en permettent de mieux voir
comment il en fallu dur agir pour
apporter un soutien plus concret plus
plus efficace auprès de Yannick Morez
moi je pense que et le préfet a dit on
l'a bien vu déjà quand il y a eu
l'incident le plus grave à savoir
l'incendie de la maison et des voitures
le préfet ou sous préfet aurait dû
physiquement se rendre auprès du du de
Yannick Corrèze on est dans des
conditions à ce moment-là qui sont
terrifiantes puisqu'il y avait des actes
de violence sur beaucoup d'endroits
attentif en particulier le blocage du
pont de Saint-Nazaire les problèmes de
la raffinerie de Donges avec des
manifestations et des violences je
rappelle que ce pronostique
Saint-Nazaire c'est quand même 800000
euros de travaux qui ont qui ont été
réinjectés du fait de la casse de la
casse sur Nantes donc le préfet montre
bien qu'il est dans une situation à ce
moment-là qui est extrêmement tendue
extrêmement difficile
et
pour autant aujourd'hui je sais que il
revoit le film de tout ce qui s'est
passé et se dit là j'aurais dû
probablement faire si là j'aurais et si
et si ça doit se produire j'agirait de
telle et telle manière je crois qu'il
faut surtout chercher ici à en tirer les
conclusions sur la bonne manière les
bonnes pratiques lorsqu'on est face à
une situation comme celle-ci et ça va
changer beaucoup de choses et c'est ça
que souhaite Yannick Morez c'est que son
ce qu'il a vécu ne se reproduise pas et
que cette expérience parce que nous
allons la traiter parce que nous allons
analyser donne des résultats concrets on
va en parler mais juste Audrey pour
terminer puisque on a évoqué le contexte
d'après le préfet le contexte c'était
compliqué oui c'est beaucoup revenu dans
les prises de parole vous l'avez rappelé
quelques jours avant l'incendie criminel
et quelques jours après il y a eu
d'importantes manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites et d'après le
préfet c'est la raison pour laquelle
notamment il n'a pas senti certains
signaux raison pour laquelle aussi il
n'est pas allé voir le maire de
Saint-Brévin en personne après
l'incendie criminel écouter
sa décision de démission elle n'en est
pas moins en effet un échec collectif et
j'en prends ma part comme représentant
territorial de l'État à titre contextuel
la semaine au cours de laquelle a été
commise l'incendie criminel à l'encontre
de Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins a été ponctué
d'événements lourds en termes d'ordre
public la veille dans la nuit du 21 et
du 22 mars la libération de l'apompement
de Donges pour permettre la livraison
nationale de carburant à donner lieu à
des affrontements violents sur le site
pendant plusieurs heures malgré le
renfort de trois escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile
toute la journée du 22 le pont de
Saint-Nazaire
propriété du département et axe
stratégique en Loire-Atlantique a été
bloqué et fortement dégradée il n'a
d'ailleurs été réouvert à la circulation
que le lendemain
il y a le contexte on l'a évoqué hier
vous avez aussi parlé d'autres maires
qui dénonçaient un sentiment d'impunité
notamment sur les personnes qui ont
envoyé les tracts qui ont envoyé les
menaces finalement rien n'a été fait
pour remonter à savoir qui les envoyer
oui je vais organiser le 7 avril au
Pouliguen une réunion avec en présence
d'ailleurs du sous-préfet et du général
de gendarmerie auquel participait de
nombreux maires qui a porté leur
témoignage sur des affaires dont ils
avaient été victimes des violences de
toute nature et qui montrait qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y avait eu à dépôt de plainte
ça finit sans suite alors il y a à mon
avis derrière cet événement qui
malheureusement partagé assez connu le
sentiment que j'ai que beaucoup de gens
finalement sont aussi dans des
situations qui donneront pas l'objet de
plainte alors aujourd'hui le préfet
insiste beaucoup sur le fait que ce soit
fait mais
dès l'instant où cette rumeur se dépense
se répandus ça sert à rien et quand je
fais côté de la gendarmerie ils savent
que ça débouche pas se dire d'un part et
de l'autre et bien on hésite et ça il
faut y revenir il faut y revenir c'est
extrêmement important et ce comment
c'est une question des sanctions ou
c'est une question de modification de la
loi c'est la loi est là mais les
solutions
des procureurs voire ensuite du juge sur
l'application des peines pourquoi parce
que il va considérer que c'est un fait
politique classique on va considérer que
finalement c'est une pratique normale
que et on peut pas intervenir parce que
à chaque fois des élus se font insulter
moi j'étais mère en 1995 j'étais 22 ans
mère j'ai vécu ce genre de situation je
n'ai jamais déposé plainte je le faisais
pas parce que je n'y croyais pas je
croyais pas l'aboutissement de ma plante
et donc ça devient quelque chose
d'accepter et puis ça peut prendre des
proportions pour arriver à une situation
comme celle qui a vécu Yannick Morez et
le fait le gouvernement disent que les
atteintes aux élus les auteurs de
violences envers les élus doivent être
considérés comme les auteurs de
violences envers les forces de l'ordre
c'est-à-dire des sanctions pénale plus
sévères ça ça peut débloquer la
situation
dans le dans la décision d'hier il y a
un moment pour moi qui m'a marqué c'est
quand Yannick Morel le 15 février
adresse un courrier au procureur de la
République
et qui marque justement le danger auquel
se sent soumis et la hauteur des menaces
ce courrier je n'ai pas pu obtenir de
réponse qu'est-ce que ça a entraîné
est-ce qu'il y a eu derrière ce que ce
courrier du 15 février une enquête
préalable qui a été engagée des mesures
qui ont pu être prises pour aller
chercher les auteurs pourquoi parce que
si ceux qui menacent ce sont toutes fait
libres de poursuivre d'accentuer leur
menace parce qu'il se passe rien on peut
arriver jusqu'au-boutiste c'est-à-dire
jusqu'à un événement qui a été celui
d'incendie pourquoi les éléments
d'incendie est un élément décisif
pourquoi parce que dès qu'on passe à
cette dimension là
pas seulement mère on atteint sa famille
nous en tant qu'élu on se sent agressé
mais on peut aussi considérer que
finalement c'est malheureusement une
chose assez
fréquente mais quand cette agression
vient toucher les membres de votre
famille à ce moment-là c'est plus la
même domaine c'est plus le même domaine
c'est plus votre engagement c'est
l'engagement de tous et là vous pouvez
pas continuer et Yannick Morel s'il a
démissionné c'est parce que c'est un cas
qui impliquait une décision familiale ce
que me disait Yannick quand dernière
fois j'étais avec lui
on se promenait il me dit tu vois
ce que je ressens aujourd'hui c'est le
besoin de me retourner et mon épouse
maintenant quand elle est dans la rue
elle se dit est-ce que j'ai pas celui
qui a brûlé la maison derrière moi donc
ça vous crée gérer une tension qui est
pas acceptable peut-être un mot de
conclusion après les auditions vous
pensez que le maire a été soutenu assez
par l'État
je ne porte pas de jugement je pense je
pense sincèrement qui est des choses à
faire je dirais qu'il y a deux choses
que le que le préfet me semble avoir
parfaitement mesuré c'est quoi que
puis-je faire pour que les choses se
sont polissent pas la première chose qui
nous a dites c'est cette présence
physique c'est-à-dire il a ressenti
il a bien sûr apporté toutes les
justifications qui sont liées à ce
moment qui a été compliqué vu guerre aux
violences sur l'ensemble du département
mais il a dit à faire en gros j'y vais
tout de suite je vais voir le maire je
vais sur place et on en discute c'est la
première chose donc accentuer la
relation humaine mais la relation
physique ont beaucoup de gens comme moi
en téléphoné à envoyer des messages etc
mais je pense qu'on a tous été peut-être
passé loin et on aurait dû physiquement
être présent en disant voilà on est de
là on fait un bloc autour de toi alors
que on l'a fait mais d'une autre manière
pas en étant à ses côtés je pense que ça
c'est important le côté humain et la
présence la deuxième chose qu'a dit et
je trouve que c'est très intéressant
comme comme évolution et que sera un
effet le préfet a dit je vais réunir
l'état-major sécurité et il existe un
état majeur sécurité qui qui sous le jus
de deux personnes le préfet et le
procureur et bien ces deux c'était un
major je vais le faire le plus souvent
possible et puis surtout il y aura à
chaque fois l'ordre jours les atteintes
aux élus ce qui amènera
il n'a pas il est pas il a pas de
pouvoir sur le procureur de la
République c'est des et donc mais par
contre ça permet de discuter d'un
constituer les dialogues avec le
procureur et de suivre mieux les
affaires pour pouvoir être plus efficace
je crois qu'il va falloir se cette
organisation de proximité qu'elle soit
plus fréquente et qui permettra d'agir
et ne pas se voir tous les deux mois sur
ce sujet là donc il y aura il y aura et
c'est ce que le dit le préfet hier et je
trouve que c'est une très bonne
orientation je suis profondément
convaincu que cette affaire et grâce à
ce que l'action de Yannick Morez qui
quelque part et bien à créer un
effet va booster l'ensemble des mesures
qu'on va pouvoir prendre pour les élus
on a déjà anticipé il y a déjà des
choses qui ont été faites notamment la
loi que nous a présenté pour et au mois
de novembre au Sénat dont nous sommes
les auteurs pour la protection des élus
on va continuer à parler de ces sujets
merci Audrey à tout à l'heure oui on va
parler trafic de drogue dans les petites
communes et ce sera à suivre dans le
club on continue à parler de ces
relations élues préfet c'est aussi
l'actualité dans votre département et
justement on va à Nantes on retrouve
Emmanuel Vautier bonjour Emmanuel merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journaliste à
la rédaction de Presse Océan et on
revient avec vous Emmanuel sur les
relations entre élu locaux et préfets
vous avez publié un dossier là-dessus
oui bonjour et bien on voit bien cette
affaire Morez elle met en relation la
complexité des échanges entre les élus
les parlementaires qu'ils soient les
maires dans les conseils municipaux on
voit bien que
les municipalités les collectivités
elles ont moins de manège de marshmineux
financières avec les référents fiscales
on voit aussi que sur les questions de
sécurité les relations sont assez
complexes avec l'État les préfets en
fait nous on constate ils ont beaucoup
de pouvoir localement ils sont au cœur
de pas mal de dossiers l'urbanisme
l'environnement la santé le social et on
voit des préfets qui peuvent manier un
peu avec les élus locaux la carotte
comme le bâton et souvent on le constate
dans les rédactions on a des élus qui se
gardent bien de taper publiquement sur
leur préfet quoi pour ménager un peu
leur bonne relation
néanmoins mais nous on s'interroge
comment vous parlementaire vous faites
remonter auprès de votre préfet les
attentes de votre territoire quelle
image vous avez de ce préfet Fabrice
Rigoulet rose qui vient d'arriver en
Loire-Atlantique depuis janvier vous
dites dans Presse Océan ce matin que
c'est un peu terrible ce qui se passe
parce que finalement c'est un préfet qui
est facile d'accès plus généralement
comment est-ce que vous qualifiez les
relations entre les préfets et les élus
locaux
moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment que les
relations sont bonnes les témoignages
que m'apporte l'ensemble des des élus en
particulier président d'agglomération
montrent que la relation est tenue elle
est fréquente on les voit beaucoup sur
le terrain d'abord sur le préfet le
nouveau préfet est arrivé le 30 janvier
j'ai regardé sur mon agenda je l'ai
croisé de 27 fois alors soit c'est pour
les commémorations soit c'est pour des
inaugurations soit c'est pour des
réunions qui l'organisent sur des thèmes
des etr ou autre sujet d'État d'ailleurs
des invitations leur soient tellement
qu'on peut pas toutes les honorer donc
si en plus nous même on se rendait aux
habitations qu'on reçoit encore plus
souvent non c'est pour vous dire qu'il y
a une vraie appréciation et moi je
ressens depuis des années cette cette
volonté des préfectures et bien d'aller
le plus possible sur les terrains check
préfet alors on en change souvent
malheureusement ce qui fait que on
repart à zéro mais dès qu'un préfet
arrive en général
votre téléphone aux uns et aux autres le
préfet actuel la première chose qu'il a
faite il a été s'est rendu dans les
permanences des parlementaires et non
pas il n'a pas fait venir les gens la
préfecture mais c'est déplacé sur le
terrain pour rencontrer les
parlementaires il a il en a fait au même
avec de même avec les présidents
d'agglomération etc donc on voit qu'il y
a une activité une présence qui est
importante et ça conforte ce besoin qui
est de plus en plus peignant de cette
relation parce que on a aussi toutes les
questions je dirais liées à la vie des
communes avec les subventions d'État les
dotations de l'État que qu'on appelle la
Deux Terres la décile ou encore le fond
pour
permettre de de se transformer nos
friches en en espace naturel etc le fond
vert donc il y a plein de sujets
maintenant qui passe par par les
préfectures et qui nécessitent en la
matière des relations
régulières alors je passe sur le 0
artificiel association net qui amène
d'autres contraintes sur les communes
mais les communes sont de plus en plus
aussi dans des situations qui les
amènent à renforcer leurs liens avec les
services de la préfecture
on va parler d'un autre sujet qui touche
la ville de Nantes c'est la question de
la sécurité avec une série de fusils ces
derniers jours
vous connaissez très bien la métropole
nantaise vous avez été maire pendant 22
ans une commune de l'agglomération et
vous constatez comme tout le monde ici
sur Nantes à une forte poussée de la
violence dans les dans les quartiers
ce matin dans Presse Océan on relate que
encore mardi soir là il y a eu une
vingtaine de coups de feu de tirés dans
un quartier de nantais alors même que le
préfet avait annoncé le jour même des
renforts de CRS pour essayer d'apaiser
un peu la situation à Nantes là on une
dizaine de jours on vient d'avoir un
homme abattu et ciblessé par balle voilà
en 10 jours depuis début 2023 pardon on
est on est à deux morts par arme à feu à
Nantes et là mardi soir ils ont retrouvé
les enquêteurs 24 étui de calypset 62 et
un enquêteur nous disait c'est du
calibre de kalachnikov voilà quand on
interroge les élus locaux alors il nous
explique qu'ils font des choses là à
Nantes dans la métropole ils ont recruté
des policiers municipaux ils implantent
des caméras mais il renvoie aussi
systématiquement sur l'état en demandant
plus de renforts policiers et aussi
particulièrement à Nantes plus de
renfort pour la justice à Nantes la
question qu'on se pose aussi c'est vous
parlementaire qu'est ce que vous faites
sur ces sujets là comment vous faites
remonter à l'état les besoins sur le
territoire en matière de sécurité à
Nantes
alors nous avons plusieurs moyens nous
avons d'abord ce que nous appelons les
questions écrites ce sont des questions
qui sont adressées directement au
gouvernement qui passent par le Journal
officiel et qui pose un cas ou un sujet
précis qui nous permet ensuite au
gouvernement officiellement à nous
répondre nous pourrons parler question
orales ça c'est dans l'hémicycle
interview interpellé directement le
gouvernement et puis on peut aussi être
source de proposition sur ce que nous
constatons sous forme d'un amendement
d'une loi ou autre donc des moyens ne
manquent pas ce que nous faisons nous le
faisons aussi au contact plus direct du
ministre puisque en particulier Darmanin
et en général là tous les mercredis et
ils n'hésitent pas à la sortie des
muscles ou avant d'arriver d'échanges
avec nous si besoin est-ce qui m'est
arrivé régulièrement le cas où cité est
malheureusement un cas qui n'est pas
seulement nantais aujourd'hui les moyens
qui ont été accrus pour la sécurité
entre considérable et emporter des
résultats dans certaines situations dans
d'autres on veut dire que effectivement
ça ne va pas assez loin mais on est
peut-être arrivé à un tel niveau de
délinquance et de danger que les moyens
devraient être à un niveau formidable
mais je crois qu'il faut il faut je sais
pas s'il faut continuer à porter
beaucoup de moyens
est-ce qu'il faut pas plutôt aller à la
source et pénaliser la source parce que
parce que ce retombe sur la question de
la justice qu'est-ce que nous disent
qu'est-ce que nous disent nos policiers
c'est arrêter les gens c'est bien mais
les arrêter plusieurs fois c'est trop et
ça finit par être un peu lassant de voir
qu'on retrouve toujours les mêmes dans
la délinquance merci
Joël gavottier d'avoir été avec nous la
Une de Presse Océan c'est l'audition
hier du préfet au Sénat audition au
Sénat le préfet assume c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci Emmanuel vous dit et
merci beaucoup Joël gario d'avoir été
avec nous pendant cette première
demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on va revenir sur le
trafic de drogue débat sur le trafic de
drogue qui s'étend dans les petites
villes et dans les villes moyennes ce
sera à suivre mais d'abord on accueille
notre invité politique c'est franchise